the movie opens up on a hilly road in
China where a woman is asking for a lift
it appears as if her car is broken down
a truck driver eagerly offers to help
but the woman ignores him thinking he's
a pervert shortly after a decent looking
man arrives in a car and the woman
quickly gets in but sadly her decision
turns out to be fatal as she finds a
mutilated human hand near her seat this
proves that the innocent looking man is
actually a serial killer the very next
minute he stops his car grabs a wrench
and bludgeons the woman to death a few
days later a public bus containing
several passengers is traveling through
the same road Wang an insurance agent is
keeping the driver Tony entertained by
telling him about how a woman went
missing some days ago in this very Place
meanwhile an announcement on the radio
informs everyone that there has been a
serious accident in a nearby Junction
because of which all roads are blocked
one of the passengers Lee mentions that
he has to reach his job on time so the
driver Tony suggests they take a detour
via an off-road nobody objects to the
decision and so the doomed Journey
Begins along the way they enter a dark
tunnel which Tony reveals he has never
come across nonetheless he continues
driving but suddenly a mysterious man
comes in the way forcing the boss to a
halt everyone is terrified as to what
he's doing in the middle of the dark
tunnel but the man turns out to be a
passenger and he too gets on the bus Lee
who is reading a newspaper finds out
that the mysterious man is a wanted
criminal so he covertly takes out a
knife for protection there are two women
on the bus Sarah an aspiring model and a
jing a pregnant lady as for kids a pair
of twin siblings Park and Fang are
present the brother Fang seems to be
autistic but his sister is always there
to look after him after 20 minutes of
driving the bus is still inside the
tunnel so Tony starts suspecting
something's up he knows that the longest
tunnel in the country is just 11
kilometers long which takes roughly 10
minutes to cross hence the group decides
to turn around and head back the way
they came from but surprisingly even
after 30 minutes of traveling at full
speed the entrance does not show up it's
an endless dark tunnel which shows no
signs of any other living organisms
scared the driver Tony stops the bus and
everyone gets out to inspect strangely
the pregnant Lady Jang finds her mobile
phone which she had accidentally dropped
about an hour earlier near the entrance
this proves that the tunnel is not an
ordinary one when everyone starts
panicking Lee takes charge of the
situation and tells everyone to calm
down he also decides to walk on foot for
a few hours to find help but since it's
very easy to get lost in the tunnel he
wants to take a long rope for better
navigation Lee will be carrying one end
of the rope and walking while the other
end will be held by the insurance guy
Wang luckily for him the pregnant lady
has plenty of knitting Wool with her
this is the first time I've ever seen
knitting come in handy as a hobby before
he departs the mysterious man who
stopped the bus earlier also expresses
his desire to join him and to leave
reluctantly agrees along the way the two
introduce each other and the man's name
is revealed to be Chan however he
doesn't talk about his work or family
after a while it starts getting foggy
and the passenger is near the boss see
two figures approaching them from the
other end scared they get ready to face
whatever confronts them but to their
surprise the figures turn out to be none
other than Lee and Chan somehow they
have again ended up at Ground Zero the
place from where they took off it gets
even weirder here as Wang is still
holding one end of the Rope he
experiences a sudden tug when she end
pulls it from the other end despite them
being adjacent to each other the tunnel
is straight but yet it leads people to
the same place again and again like an
endless loop ah we said the title
realizing that they have been trapped
Lee suggests everyone gather their food
items and ration them wisely then all
the four men head out to inspect the
place while the three ladies and the
autistic Fang rest inside the boss it's
been only 30 minutes but when Jing wakes
up she finds out that the entire bus is
covered in dust taken aback she wakes
everyone up and quickly rushes outside
at the same time the men also arrive and
find the boss in a dilapidated condition
Tony immediately goes to check on the
food but finds that everything has
become rotten this proves that not only
has is the tunnel endless but time also
moves very differently here a single
hour of the outside world equals a week
here when they return back to the bus a
map of the entire tunnel is waiting for
them it appears as if someone dropped it
off and left without a trace Lee deduces
that someone is playing with them and
immediately takes up the challenge he
places the map on a table and starts
analyzing the place just then the lights
unexpectedly go out and when they come
back on Lee has vanished instead a
bloody Trail is seen which the group
wearily follows now with Lee abducted or
possibly killed the mysterious man Chan
takes charge of the group The Bloody
Trail leads them to a wall which appears
to be Hollow Unbreaking it they come
across a strange room which has a lot of
wanted pictures a bunch of severed hands
and most importantly an engineering
diagram of the place it shows that there
are six separate tunnels in total with
one leading to another she introduces
that in order to escape they have to
cross all six tunnels he also assumes
that this secret room will have an
entrance that will lead to the second
tunnel as the group group continues
searching the room they find a weird
calendar with all the dates showing July
15th Chan realizes that it's a clue and
when he rips the calendar off of the
wall a secret wooden door is revealed
after everyone leaves the television in
the room starts showing a woman who has
been trapped inside a small cave next
the group enters the second tunnel which
strangely also has their bus parked at
the exact same spot they wonder if they
have arrived at Ground Zero but upon
checking realize that the tunnel is the
exact same but in a different time zone
the group quickly heads inside the bus
which is now wrapped with barbed wire
and starts looking for food they find a
carton of instant noodles but by this
time the driver Tony has become hostile
and greedy he finds a gun in one of the
seats and threatens the others to hand
over all the food items fearing for
their lives the group reluctantly
complies since time is moving at a rapid
rate all of them feel hungry instantly
and this is slowly turning the group
into animals after a while the model
Sarah can't bear the hunger anymore so
she goes to Tony with a deal in exchange
for a packet of instant noodles she is
willing to sell her body Tony
immediately agrees and the two make
passionate love while they're at it Wang
sneaks inside the bus and grabs a packet
for himself Wang's a genius however Tony
catches wind of this and starts beating
him to a pulp Wang's not a genius but
before he can finish the insurance guy
off someone stabs him from behind soon
the rest of the group arrives at the
scene and is shocked to witness the
murder despite this Wang is unconcerned
and he starts searching for a packet of
food that he dropped earlier when he
crouches beneath the bus he finds a
manhole the group immediately pushes the
boss and enters the manhole through
which they reach another Mysterious Room
this one also has some strange pictures
and mutilated human parts in it moreover
the television shows the woman from
earlier slowly being drowned inside the
cave disregarding this the group
searches for an exit route and again
finds the same calendar there on
removing it another Secret Door is
revealed soon everyone goes through and
they eventually reach the third tunnel
but to their surprise this tunnel is wet
and darker than before the bus is also
present there but it has been overrun by
rodents and snakes desperate for food
Wang eats some rotten noodles which he
regrets instantly seeing him in this
condition Jing pitties him and hands him
a biscuit but Wang becomes increasingly
aggressive and demands the entire packet
when she refuses he surprisingly brings
out a gun and steals everyone's food at
gunpoint but even after this his reign
of terror continues he deduces that they
found a secret passage every time one of
them dies for instance they found the
wall when Lee was abducted and the
manhole when Tony was stabbed hence he
threatens to shoot one of the remaining
survivors to ensure that he escapes the
place Chan tries to calm him down but
Wang does not listen instead he forces
the innocent Jing to shoot Xi'an in the
shoulder after this the maniac takes the
twins to the nearby room and starts
beating them up when Fang tries to save
her brother Wang brutally eliminates her
by firing at her multiple times the poor
autistic boy Park can just SOB as his
sister slowly breathes her last the
out-of-control Wang then attempts to
strangle Sarah but before he can do so
someone impales him from behind Now with
an additional two people dad the group
find a secret passage through which they
reach the fourth tunnel which is a
psychedelic tunnel just then Jin goes
into labor and rests on the side with
Park while an injured Chen and Sarah had
to investigate the boss the Psychedelic
nature of the place makes Sarah
hallucinate and she starts seeing people
scared she comes out of the bus and
heads in the opposite direction where
several dead bodies are lying around
there she notices a mirror and as she
stares into it someone approaches her
from behind and finishes her off
meanwhile chian returns to Jang who has
given birth to a baby boy the remaining
three then proceed forward but along the
way it is revealed that the little boy
has passed away Chan tries to convince
Jing to keep going but just then she
takes out a knife and stabs him to death
surprisingly after a while he wakes up
in a secret compound it appears as if he
has woken up from some sort of
experiment then we are taken to a top
secret military meeting this is where
everything finally unfolds an army
General reveals that the serial killer
from the star part of the movie James
has been caught the problem is that he
was apprehended from a car wreck in a
totally vegetative state and now he has
fallen into a coma James had kidnapped
and murdered several women but one
particular named Sierra is rumored to
still be alive the problem is that no
one knows where she is locked up except
for the serial killer himself and since
he's in a coma it's impossible to
interrogate him hence the military has
decided to collaborate with the best
Brain Research Institute in the country
their plan is to conduct the memory
transfusion with James in order to tap
into his subconscious and eventually
figure out about the victim's
whereabouts yesterday a remarkable
psychotherapist of The Institute finally
broke into James's Consciousness and
found certain Clues the psychotherapist
is revealed to be none other than Xi'an
one of the army generals then asserts
that they need to have faith in Shan
because he above all others is more
concerned about the victim's safety it
turns out that the victim Sierra is none
other than Chin's wife this is where all
the events begin to make sense as
everything that we saw earlier
transpired inside James's
subconsciousness however chien's job is
far from over in yesterday's experiment
he managed to find a preliminary clue
from a calendar on the wall that his
wife is imprisoned near Shang River but
the situation is critical because of the
heavy downpour in the next 36 hours all
caves on either banks of the river will
be completely flooded by the rising
River hence putting Sierra's life at
risk as a result Chia needs to tap into
James's subconscious once again tomorrow
so that he can find more clues about
Sierra's exact location that night as
Gian is sitting by himself the Army
General approaches him to ask about the
progress Shan then starts sharing his
experience inside James's Consciousness
and remembers that the date July 15 1996
often appeared on calendars the chief
explains that it's the date where the
serial Killer's parents both died during
that fateful day his father found out
that his mother had an affair with a
driver this resulted in a big argument
between the two which ended with his
mother stabbing his father before
committing the unthinkable himself Jan
is taken aback by the Revelation but he
continues sharing his experience he says
that in James's inner world he was able
to see both his dark side and his good
side but in the end the good side failed
the serial killer himself was actually a
tunnel engineer hence when he went into
coma he began to establish a tunnel in
his brain as the symbolic carrier of his
chaotic Consciousness the tunnel in his
Consciousness is just a dead Loop which
leads to Nowhere when Xian entered
James's brain his initial Target was to
lead him out of this endless loop so
that James could wake up from his coma
however he didn't expect there to be so
many split personalities thus Chan had
to communicate with all of them so that
he could find clues about his wife's
imprisonment his new mission was to find
the real criminal among these
personalities and interrogate him or her
for the answer as he bonded with these
personalities he found out more about
them the best one was Lee who resembles
James's healthy and rational side there
was hope that this good personality
could outweigh the others and get James
out of this Loop unfortunately he
suddenly disappeared after the Lights
Went Out in the tunnel The Disappearance
of this personality resulted in the
chaos of the situation the second
personality was the driver Tony who
eventually became violent this resembles
James's violent personality the third
and fourth personalities were Wang and
Sarah who resembled James's inner
projection of his own mother and father
his father was an insurance salesman
while his mom was a model the sad thing
is that when the father was abusive to
James his mother didn't care much about
him and instead ended up having an
affair with their driver this was
represented when Sarah made out with the
driver Tony just for food the fifth was
the pregnant lady Jing resembling his
ideal image of a mother although it is a
good personality it didn't quite
suppress his dark side so it also met
its Doom the sixth and seventh
personalities were the twins who
resemble his childhood personality
autistic weird feminish but very
talented in math and space physics but
there is one more personality that was
not on the boss it is the fiercest
personality and always hidden in the
dark this is the personality that
secretly killed Lee the driver Tony and
one Wang but to find out more Chien
needs another experiment the next day
comes and she and undergoes the second
phase of the memory transfusion this
time he directly confronts James and
demands his wife's whereabouts however
the cold-blooded killer doesn't want to
give up the information so quickly
instead he starts talking about how he
hates his mother for killing his dad
this insecurity towards women is why he
abducts them and finishes them off
saying this much he takes Chan to
different parts of his subconscious
where various events of his life are
being played out however focusing on his
mission she and disregards all of them
and confronts the autistic personality
Park the weakest of James's
personalities he tries manipulating the
boy to give up the coordinates to his
wife's location but his twin sister Fang
stops him following this Gian is
transported to a cinema Hall where he
encounters the real evil behind all the
murders inside the tunnel it is revealed
to be none other than Xi'an himself it
turns out that James's subconscious is
so messed up and evil that the one who
looks into it also starts thinking like
a serial killer the evil Chien reveal
that he didn't want Sierra to be saved
so he killed the people inside the
tunnel one by one including the newborn
baby suddenly the scared autistic boy
Park appears on stage and so does
chian's wife Park slowly approaches
Sierra to kill her but at the last
moment he backs out taking this is the
perfect opportunity the real chian
approaches the scared boy and requests
him to wake up and tell the authorities
about his wife's location surprisingly
Park agrees and walks away then the evil
Chien takes him to a different setting
with the two get ready for one final
showdown soon the two start fighting
with one another but when the real qian
feels like he's Victorious another clone
of evil chian shows up implying that
he's indestructible elsewhere the rain
has started pouring in and Sierra is
almost neck deep in the water it is only
a matter of minutes before she drowns to
death back inside James's
subconsciousness the real chian pleads
to let him back into his world but his
evil doppelganger refuses to listen just
then the real Chien comes up with a plan
he realizes that if he commits the
unthinkable the evil Chien will also die
and with this all of the evil inside
James will go away and as soon as he
goes through with his plan the evil
Chien Fades away and at the hospital
James wakes up being a totally changed
man he immediately tells the authorities
about Sierra's location in this way
Sierra is saved in the nick of time but
Chien doesn't wake up the movie ends as
he wanders around the endless tunnel
indicating that he will never return
home subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching